well thank you for inviting me to give
this lecture and really I want to I want
to we echo in the opposite way I guess
echos are in the opposite way what
Michael said because I had many of those
really good half hours or 45 minutes or
whatever it is today I really want to
thank everybody I talked to today I had
a really good time and I will be
hard-pressed to give back you know a
fraction of what I got from all of you
but I will try okay so you know if I was
going to list what are the kind of key
secrets of the neural circuits allowed
to do interesting and powerful things I
think I would I would probably start the
list by saying all neurons get so many
inputs thousands of inputs from other
neurons and that's got to be part of how
they work so well and you know you can
use a cortical neuron like this as an
example of that but you know everybody
would say the grand champ of receiving
thousands of other inputs is the
Purkinje cell of the cerebellar cortex
which has hunt gets hundreds of
thousands of other inputs so you might
think that the cerebral cortex is a
further example of this theme but that's
not really correct and it's not really
correct if you look at a little more
detail in a cortical circuit over here
or a cellar cerebellar circuit over here
because here if you look in cortex all
of the neurons have that property that
they receive at least a lot of input but
in in cerebellar cortex things are very
different in particular this little cell
where you can actually see it synapse if
there is the inputs it's receiving the
cerebellar granule cell is it receives
on average about four connections from
other cells whereas this guy appears
getting hundreds of thousands this guys
getting four furthermore this is the
majority of the cells in your brain so
when you say you know it all works by
many connections you're you're not
talking about the majority of the
neurons
actually in your brain so I think the
work I'm going to talk about really got
started by looking at this difference
between these two kinds of circuits a
circuit where there's a relatively
uniform high number of connections and
every neuron and another circuit whether
this incredible divergence of almost a
hundred thousand factor between this
cell and this cell so what's going on
here so in this case the majority of the
cells in the cerebral cortex get an
input from only a few other neurons
that's the idea
so let me just give you a quick tour of
the cerebellum which I'm hardly going to
talk about actually but occasionally it
will creep in so let me let me tell you
basic features so there's our friend the
most numerous neuron the granule cell so
obviously with these 50 billion cells or
whatever they are in our brains perform
a very large neural representation so
that's the real guts of cerebellar like
circuits they have neurons that form a
high dimensional representation and then
form these parallel fibers in order to
get that information to the other
neurons they in this case the Purkinje
cells that are the output those
connections are very sparse I mentioned
that there's only a handful of
connections from the mossy fibers into a
granule cell they are at least on some
scale random not across the whole
cerebellum but within local regions of
the cerebellum they appear to be random
and that's another feature you have a
very highly connected output neuron so
this is the factor of a hundred thousand
difference that I mentioned for as far
as the cerebellar cortex goes for Kinji
cell is of course the output you have
plasticity on the connections between
the granule cells or the parallel fibers
and the the output neuron and you have a
learning signal in the form of a
climbing fiber signal that affects that
plasticity so those are the basic
elements in what I'm going to call
cerebellar like circuits if they have
those that they are qualify so another
one which is in my title but I'm
actually not going to talk about because
they had too much to talk about and
different one so I'm not going to
mention this beyond that but the
electrosensory lobe in electric fish
which handles the electric signalling
processing has has a very similar
structure and has all of these features
it has granule cells with a few
connections that make parallel fibers
plasticity you name it same same idea
and I don't know maybe you've already
done this but if you want to hear great
talk about the system you should invite
a my my colleague Nate cell to talk
about it
ok so here's another kind of funny
diagram you can think for a while why is
he using such a weird-looking diagram to
give an idea of the cerebellar cortex
but basically the idea of your input
comes in through mossy fibers goes to
granule cells goes to Purkinje cells and
you have a learning signal that affects
plasticity there that's the basic
structure now I want to talk about
mostly about another analog system that
has the same basic structure I'll show
you that in a second as as a cerebellar
cortex that's the mushroom body in flies
and I'm going to talk about it because
we know a lot about it so we'll really
be able to dig into the nitty-gritty in
that case the input is olfactory it goes
through something called projection
neurons to kenyon cells those are the
analog the granule cells to something
called mushroom body output neurons
which is the analog of the Purkinje
cells it has a learning signal same
basic structure ok so why did I use this
kind of funny diagram no sorry I'm not
going to punch line doesn't come yet I
want to show you a little bit more about
the olfactory system in the fly so the
fact of our system in the fly starts on
in 10 i which have a factory receptor
neurons that's what you're seeing in
green those send axons in 2 then now you
they're reappearing here in this image
to an object called the antennae lobe
where there are glomeruli much like in
your olfactory bulb a particularly
scepter type sends its axons to a
particular glomerulus the signal is
picked up in that glomerulus by
projection neurons that was what you're
seeing in yellow projection neurons go
up to 2 structures in the brain this is
a lateral horn which I'm not going to
talk about and this is the mushroom body
this
kind of l-shaped thing which is
constructed from the kenyan sells the
parallel fibers that i mentioned as one
characteristic of this system or what
make this L shape those are all parallel
fibers of Kenyan cells now here's
another view where you can see the
Kenyan cells in their entirety so cell
bodies up here there's a area called the
calyx here which receives the input
that's now I'm sorry but I've changed
the color scheme but anyway projection
neuron coming up makes connections here
and then these are the axons I talked
about Kenyan cells axons are completely
contained within the mushroom body so
they're not outputting on there like
granule cells making these copious
parallel fibers and then the analog of
the Purkinje cell is this mushroom body
output neuron here you're seeing one of
them it grabs hold of input from those
parallel axons here and then sends off a
signal that does go out from the
mushroom body carries out that signal
okay so let me come back to this so why
did I use this funny diagram this funny
diagram actually comes from a book
written in 1961 about perceptrons by
Frank Rosenblatt and and here's his
diagram of the perceptron so has the
same structure he called the perceptron
or the elementary perceptron this three
unit structure consisting of input a
very large representation what he called
a unit and an output which is analogous
to these three stages that I just showed
you for example in the mushroom body
okay this this book is a sobering read
for anybody who does either machine
learning or theoretical neuroscience
it's completely remarkable I I only
recently really looked at it Rosenblatt
understood that this was a very powerful
structure he understood that it relied
critically on these so called
a units the granule cells and and the
fact that they're the most numerous cell
in your brain might suggest that they
might be useful for something he study
backpropagation of learning in this
system in 1961 he understood the
implications of the limited range of
these synapses which is something that I
thought I had done originally not very
many years ago and I [ __ ] up
Rosenblatt and here's another diagram
from Rosenblatt that can be mapped on to
this system and you probably know this
is not that the greatest moment in MIT
history but we we know more about this
this circuit from a follow-up paper that
was by Mincy Paulo a book actually by
Minsky and Papert in 1969 that did a
mathematical analysis of this that
actually is less than the mass of the
original mathematical analysis but they
did something complicated and we've kind
of used it that terminology they dated
some funny I guess you would say which
is they just removed that part of the
circuit so they considered this as a
perceptron and today when we say
perceptron we actually mean this we've
taken the Minsky and Papert terminology
that that is in this much more limited
form and they showed that this doesn't
work very well anymore then you're you
know cerebellum would probably work too
well without the granule cells so you
know the I won't be this day there's a
much-maligned book but anyway something
else more positive happened in 1969
which is the David Marr considered this
circuit in the cerebellum and and you
know in a really groundbreaking paper
considered primarily this part the
learning that took place at the output
and he correctly kind of conjectured
what it was all about and but he's less
impressive at this level I mean he a
little bit like miski and paper didn't
know exactly what to do at this level
I'm not trying to be critical but what
I'm trying to say is that at that time
there were these two giants around that
that that there was a lack of
communication there between these two
these are two people who both died much
young and you kind of wonder you know
what would have happened if there been a
communication between these and a bigger
appreciation of the biological part of
this circuit maybe a better appreciation
to biology over here an appreciation of
the of the machine learning over here so
I bring up that theme because we are
currently at a time where that's
happening again it's happening with a
different kind of circuit that I'll come
to at the end but I think we're at a
time where we have to get this right and
the communication between neuroscience
and the machine learning community I
think is going to be vital in the years
ahead I think if it had been better back
then better things would have happened
and you know just to add to the dream
team this would be a dream team but I
can add even more which is Tommy you've
even young Tommy and just in case that
is not enough mental power
to solve the problem we've got Francis
Crick over here so those guys should
have solved everything back then okay so
back to this diagram what I want to do
is talk about this this part of the
circuit okay and that's work that kind
of exploded over the last years maybe
starting with this paper a sort of a
reanalysis of what's going on here maybe
with a closer look at the biology so
that's the point of what I'm doing you
can see at the bottom a couple of works
that I'm talking about and in particular
I'm really going to talk about the work
of a shock between Kumar who is a
postdoc and who was actually supposed to
talk here last Tuesday and steal all my
thunder but the snowstorm wiped out his
talk so instead I get to steal his
thunder and he comes later and that's a
disadvantage of the snowstorm and then
Evan Shea for another postdoc in Richard
Axel flab so I'll tell you this go long
okay so I apologize that I've shown you
multiple diagrams but now this is my
diagram of the circuit and I'll stick to
it from now on so we have circuits like
the mushroom body consisting of a you
know medium sized input layer a much
larger
what would call be called hidden layer
in machine learning and then an output
unit that sends a signal out of the
circuit those are the b3 the purple the
green and the brown elements of this
circuit okay and as I said my interest
is in this this part of the the beast
okay so let me do some numbers so I'm
going to introduce some letters it would
be nice if you remembered them but if
you don't it's probably not fatal so I'm
going to call in the number of these
input units which in the olfactory
system or in the mushroom body are
glomeruli these are the 50 channels it
turns out in the fly 50 or factory
channels that come into this system and
carry all of the olfactory informations
now those get expanded to a larger
number of these granule type cells
kenyon cells in the mushroom body and
I'm going to call that M and M is about
a thousand in the mushroom body so what
you can see here is there's about a 20
fold expansion in the number of neurons
used to represent exactly the same
information there there is very little
there's a little bit of none'll factory
information that comes in to the Kenyan
cells but actually I haven't included
that in this count so it's pretty much
just olfactory information over more
neurons another important number that I
mentioned at the start is how many
connections do each the Veatch Kenyan
cell get in other words how many of
these projection neurons from the
glomeruli go to each Kenyan cells that's
the number K that is about 6 for the
mushroom body and the other feature of
this is that we have shown I think I
have the papers here that these
connections are indistinguishable from
random I'm going to give you some more
evidence of that in a little bit ok so
the basic idea is why can we understand
these features that that's the project
that I'm going to talk about if I do the
same thing for the cerebellar cortex
these are called multi fibers granule
cells Purkinje cells you have about
10,000 mossy fibers
going into 20,000 granule cells going
into a single per Tingy cell that's
roughly the numbers interestingly the
expansion factor is again 20 and the
number of synapses the connections is
again onto a granule cell of order you
know a half a dozen in this case four so
we're going to try to explain those so
here's my first little warmup exercise
one thing is if this representation is
so big presumably what you're trying to
do is build a very diverse
representation of the information coming
in if I have information coming in 50
channels and I spread it out over a
thousand chances it's Ari I don't want
to just you know make Xerox copies of it
that what would be the point I it's not
going to get any less noisy than it
already is so the most it you know
obvious assumption is that these cells
are supposed to be different
all thousands of these cells should be
different to make a very diverse
representation so I can argue here I'm
going to generalize and say well suppose
I have K connections here and I have
these n 50 glomeruli coming in and I
have in this picture four connections
how many different ways can I build a
Kenyan cell well that would just be n
choose K right the binomial coefficient
how many ways can I choose K inputs from
the end possibilities and now I can say
well how many different Kenyan cells
could I build or what's the probability
that if they do this randomly they all
end up different and that number so the
probability that if I randomly now make
a whole bunch of Kenyan cells just by
pulling out connections the probably of
that they're all different is given by
this expression and this Z and I don't
expect it to be familiar to you but this
is the answer to what often is called
the birthday paradox it's this paradox
that if you ask it like in this room it
there's an incredibly high probability
that two people have the same birthday
and and it seems I know it's a paradox
because you don't need very many people
to have that to be true anyway this is
the formula for it so we can calculate
the probabilities if you just randomly
wire these guys up that
all be different that probability grows
very rapidly to one that they'll all be
different and if you go up to about 95
percent or so you see well six ought to
do it in other words by the time you
make six connections you can make all
the Kenyans cells different so that's
that sort of a first order magnitude
just to see are we on the right track if
you do the same number using the numbers
that I gave you for the cerebellum you
get four so okay good start it's not
right decide this argument but it's a
good start okay and you know any
argument that works that well should be
pushed even harder so this is just a
little exercise to get me to the next
part of the talk but you could argue
here can I can I look at the
distribution because when I say here
that there's six connections there
aren't exactly six connections on every
cell there's a distribution with a mean
of about six or seven so could I argue
how many connections a Kenyan cell gets
more aggressively and that's what I'm
doing here Kenyan cells get their
synapses in claws those are you saw kind
of pictures of those that's the say they
grab hold of the presynaptic terminal
with a claw and they have different
numbers of claws I'll show you the real
data over here and so you might argue
well what if you started let's say
making two connections until you ran out
of of combination so it became very
likely you were going to repeat and then
you did three and then you did four and
then you did five always requiring that
you know there's a 95% chance of getting
all of them different then you get a
distribution like this and if you look
at the data it's a pretty good match
actually so again you think well I'm
doing pretty well except that I've
cheated and I haven't shown you that
that this has a tail on it and this
doesn't but as I say this was just an
excuse to get me to the next step the
next thing okay so the next result is
come from a really a beautiful study
really led by Albert Cardona at and that
is an e/m reconstruction of the entire
mushroom body of the larval fly not the
adult fly although IEM reconstructions
of parts of the mushroom
body of the adults I will be coming out
pretty soon too so this is a wonderful
study a wealth of data
it's a connectome of a whole structure
and we did similar type analyses for it
now here these are the distributions of
claw numbers in the larvae and you know
not surprisingly it's just a leftward
shifted version kind of of this
distribution larvae have less glomeruli
it's exactly what you would expect these
numbers here in in this case the data is
the bar and and surprisingly that theory
is the one with the error bars anyway
the theory is from a random model kind
of what you would expect it's not bad
except that unlike the adult you notice
the adult doesn't have any single claws
so there's that would be a canyon cell
it only gets one one input the larvae
has lots of those and way more than you
would expect we would expect that if you
tried to make this many single claw
Kenyon cells you should get lots of
repeat and the whole name of the game is
to avoid repeats so so we might
immediately wondered what on earth is
going on here in in the single claw guys
except if you think about it a little
bit so this is a developing animal
obviously starts out with no Kenyon
cells and they start to grow and a clue
here is that those single claw Kenyon
cells are the first born Kenyon cells so
if you think about it suppose you had n
inputs 21 in the case of the larvae and
you are trying to connect them to only
21 Kenyon cells in other words you have
this case where m equals in and you
wanted them all to be different well
clearly the way to do that is just a
hook come up one to one and it's
guaranteed to be different so in this
case you don't need random wiring you
just need one-to-one wiring and indeed
that's exactly what happens
if you look at the single claw Kenyon
cell connections here are the different
glomeruli the differentl factory
channels and these are different Kenyon
cells all single klopse they're
perfectly one-to-one and so the system
does that but then as it grows more Mork
Kenyon cells now if you try to do the
same thing with with
connections the combinatory gets
complicated you've got to keep track
that I got one from the purple and the
green so you better not get from them
you know it's too complicated so the
most logical thing at that point is just
say go random and indeed that's exactly
what happens so here is the e/m
reconstruction of the left side mushroom
body and that here there are two clogged
eyes there are three closet for closet
five closet 6 claws and now we do an
analysis of this is completely
consistent with random and now what we
didn't have in the adult we did a
similar analysis a while ago in the
adult but we didn't have the both sides
in this case we have both sides and I
think you can see by eyeball but we also
did this statistics that there's
absolutely no relationship between those
two sides there completely there's no
correlation there they're completely
random with respect to each other so it
really looks like that's the strategy
hook up the first 21 in a systematic
manner and then just go random and keep
in mind that the two sides are different
we're going to come back to the fact of
how come the fly can think one thought
if it's got two different sides of its
mushroom body ok so now I'm going to do
a better job or I'm not going to do a
better job as shuch is going to do a
better job at really analyzing this and
I'm going to I'm going to kind of
quickly go through his results and if
you are interested I hope you're
interested then go to his talk when he
comes out in the coming week sometime so
again we're trying to explain these
numbers why why is the expansion ratio
20 in particular and why is the
connection number 6 and what a shook
derived was that for interesting tasks
for example tasks in which this output
neuron has to categorize odors let's say
as aversive or repetitive that there's a
quantity called the dimension of the
representation that directly is a
measure of how well this system is going
to do that so you can look at the
dimension of this kenyon cell
representation and really say how good
are these Kenyan cells at supporting
that kind of time
and so we're going to do a calculation
of that dimension or he's going to do a
calculation of that I mentioned under a
couple of assumptions I you know he did
lots of calculations but I just want to
show you this one cuz it's in it sort of
a highlight so we're going to assume
these these snaps are kind of Orden of
the same strength and that they're
positive which they are they're excited
Tory synapses and we're going to put on
a constraint because we want to optimize
the system and the constraint is going
to be that you're only allowed a certain
number of synapses so that that's the
quantity K times n so it's as if you
know these projection neurons are
allowed to make so many thousand
synapses but we're going to allow them
to make many synapses on a few Kanyon
cells or a few synapses on a lot of
Kenyan cells and see where this
dimension is up is maximal so here's the
result of that calculation you find a
peak indeed so this is the number of
connections per per Kenyan cell this is
the dimension it goes up to about there
but it disappointingly does not peak at
the right number so the average numbers
over here on the other hand we we left
out something when we did this
calculation the mushroom body is
inhibited sort of globally by a single
neuron in each side called a pl here's a
picture of the neuron and you can see it
just plastering
the whole mushroom body if you put that
effect in you get this curve which bingo
peeks right at the right spot so I just
showed this to show that you know even
theorists sometimes do get the wrong
answer but we can fudge and fix it but
it's not a fudge right there really
earthen abyssion and furthermore if you
do this calculation for the cerebellar
cortex it's just a different set of
numbers you find a peak quite a sharp
peak at four it turns out that this
curve doesn't matter if you put in in
abyssion it's say with the numbers the
inhibition has no effect so we can
explain why Kay is so small and the
other thing is we can kind of explain
the expansion ratio if you look at this
dimensionality as a function of the
expansion ratio which is remember in
this case would be the number of Kenyan
cells compared to
number of input channels it looks like
that it saturates and it sort of starts
to saturate a twenty so at this point
you don't gain much from building the
system any bigger than that and for the
cerebellar cortex likewise it may be
twenty is a little low but again you're
getting into the range these two F's are
the sparseness of the activity which is
something that you can also compute but
I'm not going to get into it so what I'm
trying to convince you up here is that
we can roughly account for the
properties of this system on simple
optimization principles okay now I want
to go to this feature that there's not
one mushroom body but two one on each
side of the brain I mentioned that and
the point is that these synapses I've
just argued or random and they're
completely unrelated on the two sides of
your brain so the question is here that
that means - any older you're going to
get a completely different pattern of
activity in these canyon cells than in
these can yourselves on the left and
right side of the fly's brain but
ultimately you're going to have it an
output coming in the two sides and
presumably you don't want one half the
brain saying avoid that odor and the
other half of the brain saying no
approach that odor and and you certainly
would hear because it's all random
however there is something shared by the
two sides of your brain namely when you
learn something hopefully you learn it
on both sides so we're going to ask the
question if you have a learning
experience and it's going to be a single
odor learning experience so we're going
to imagine this model fly being exposed
to one odor and being taught that that
odor let's say is dangerous just a
single odor and then we're going to ask
whether the responses that's going to
set these connections right because
these are whether there are our plastic
that's going to set these two sets of
connections it's going to set them
different from each other and then we're
going to look at the output of these two
output neurons and ask are they the same
not just for that odor but across odors
how correlated is it just by having one
experience
by the two sides your brain how how
unified a person can you be okay that's
the question and and what we do is just
I think I settle this you don't need the
equations but we just train the two
sides to a single odor and it which is
the same and then we just look at the
correlation coefficient of the responses
of the two output neurons very simple
and you get a curve like this and so the
answer is if you have enough Kanyon
cells in fact even a single training
experience can you make the two sides of
your brain pretty unified the amazing
thing is that this experiment that has
actually been done this is where it's
cool to work on flies so um I think I
have the well I don't want to put up the
points so I'll put up the reference when
I put at the points but glenn Turner's
lab did an experiment in which they
exposed a fly to a bunch of orders and
and recorded from the same output neuron
on the two sides of the same fly and
here's what they got these different
numbers refer to different parts of the
of the mushroom body different outputs
of the mushroom body that are fed by
different numbers of Kenyan cells so we
put them on the right thing and you know
they really fit these points they I gave
this talk at janila and and Yoshi also
was in the court hall and we had this
point over here and he he just pointed
out he said oh you forgot there's extra
inputs to this compartment and when you
do that it's going to fall right on the
curve and so we did that and he was
right it did so so in other words this
fly with a true and or the Flies that
were subject to this experiment were as
you know
unified on their two sides as randomness
could make them given a small number of
shared learning experiences and given
that you know you spend their life in a
little jar the shared learning
experiences are probably not bad
rich so it works okay so ah good I got
to get hustling here a little bit all
right so I showed you this picture of
the mushroom body but what you might
imagine is that this output neuron
is is not all by itself look at all
these axons you know we're just waiting
to be to be synapsed on with and in fact
that's true
so the mushroom body consists of 15
compartments each compartment is fed by
a few output none it is is connected to
a spew output 9 what you're seeing here
in color are the dendrites from a number
of these output neurons so they form
this tiling of the mushroom bodies not
unlike where you have Purkinje cells
that go in these parallel you know kind
of leaves in the in the in the
cerebellum and furthermore and I've sort
of been ignoring the learning sister up
to now there are dopamine neurons and
the dopamine neurons tile in exactly the
same way so there are a set of dopamine
neurons for this compartment another for
this compartment another for this
compartment and so there's this perfect
match between dopamine neurons which are
the learning signal I'll show you that
in a second and and and these
compartments and so of course it's
become kind of an industry I think I
have that doing that on the next slide
yeah it's become an industry to
characterize what are these different
compartments do and you you get a better
pattern that this vertical lobe of the
mushroom body is associated with
avoidance so if you activate these guys
up to genetically you tend to get
avoidance behavior and this lobe of the
mushroom body is associated with
approach again if you activate those
neurons if you now look at the dopamine
neurons you can train flies to either
avoid or approach an odor by not
shocking them or feeding them but just
by activating the dopamine neurons again
up to genetically and what you find is
the dopamine neurons here are associated
with reward and the dopamine neurons
here are associated with punishment and
if you look at this is backwards right
so what happens is the dopamine actually
weakens the synapse so a fly you know
that approaches with joy some odor size
is just fears it less
it's kind of a depressing way view of
life but that's that's what happens you
turn down your avoidance and you fall in
love I guess okay so this is the classic
picture this is the Marr model of course
Marv didn't do this but it's actually
the Heisenberg model of the mushroom
body where you have odor coming in on
these parallel fibers the canyon sells
synapsing on different output neurons
and then these synapses are modified by
the activity of dopamine which tends to
weaken those synapses again it's like
the prep the ltd at the Purkinje granule
soda Purkinje synapse
as a result odors can be associated with
different mushroom body outputs and
therefore you know the fly can learn to
like some orders and just like other
orders okay so I want to tell you one
example of work from Richard Axel's lab
mostly the work of Daisuke Ettore that
it involves this kind of search for the
different compartments see if we can
find one that's interesting and
understand what it's doing the
compartment in question is called alpha
prime 3 it's one of the ones you know
it's just one of the compartments in the
lobes of the mushroom body and it has an
Associated dopamine neuron called ppl
one alpha Prime 3 and we want to look
into what does this compartment -
alright so here's a video of Daisuke dog
you got to listen to it
talked over to Raymond I got started
again sorry about that okay okay
see the alerts and he doesn't do
anything okay so this dog had an
alerting response and an unusual sound
occurred and then he instantly stored in
memory and what happened again he said I
know what that is it's just some gone
going off so we did the daisuke dog
experiment in the fly and it was done
very cleverly by Daisuke so B I'm going
to show you sequential pictures of
slides that have been ducted so that
this some kind of dust was put on the
Flies and that caused them to groom very
vigorously they don't like to have the
dust on them and so here's a fly I hope
you can see it's vigorously grooming
itself at that point a valve was open
but nothing went in except the solvent
and the fly just ignores it
he's very busily grooming okay now the
middle one is also grooming now an odor
comes in that the fly has never been
exposed to kind of freaks him out he
stops blooming kind of walks around a
little bit and then you'll go back to
grooming and then here's a fly on the
second exposure to the odor
now the odor comes on fly completely
ignores it this is Daisuke dog right
it's the you know he basically trained a
dog to do what the Flies do okay so
what's the basis of this in other words
flies will respond about 50% of the time
to a novel odor when they're grooming
and that that response will go away on
the other hand this is just the control
which is a solvent that doesn't spell
all right so so in the alpha prime X
compartment let me start this again
these are daisuke slides so it must
accomplish okay so um this is now
recording from the output neuron of this
alpha prime 3 compartment one of these M
bond output neurons that I've been
talking about and this is an odors being
being released and the flat and this
neuron responded to that order this is
just an indication of the order of
concentration and what you can see over
time is that response goes away it's
even sort of replaced by inhibition so
this is you know you would say okay this
is sensory adaptation I have to work a
little harder but this neuron responds
the first time to a novel odor and very
quickly that response is shut down and
and again we're looking for something
that was reported novelty response so
what we want is something that responds
shuts down and and recognizes out here
oh this is a familiar odor but it better
respond to a novel odor we don't want to
just completely shut the neuron down and
so I'll show you that in a second anyway
this is just the summary data it
responds very vigorously in early trials
and it either doesn't respond or
sometimes it's even inhibited in later
trials okay now here's the the the one
that I'll do kind of quickly but the
idea is if it adapts to one odor you
don't want it to adapt to all odors
that's just a system shutting down and
and these it's a little hard to see but
this showed that they're always adapt to
one odor show a novel odor you know and
and or you know have the fly exposed to
novel odor and you get back the original
response back to the original spot so
this is an older specific kind of
adaptation so novel odors still make the
system respond but it recognizes that it
has seen or smelled that odor before
okay now you want this to last for a
little while and in experiments how
daisuke could show that it lasts
somewhere between 20 and 60 minutes so
here you can see the adapt adapt ting to
an odor here's a novel odor and that
that gradually went away by 60 minutes
it was gone so the fly can recognize
that it's been exposed to an odor for
about half an hour or something like
that okay now you might say well how do
you know this isn't just sensory
adaptation occurring someplace earlier
so here's an example
of an experiment looking at the Kenyan
cell responses remember the Kenyan cells
feed into this guy this guy adapts very
strongly Kenyan cells do adapt but not
nearly as strongly and furthermore
looking at other compartments remember
we have these 15 compartments other
compartments respond the M bonds respond
to these odors but that response
sometimes it even a facilitate it
doesn't go away over time so this seems
relatively unique this is not all of the
compartments but all of the ones that
that daisuke looked at now this should
then start to look familiar at least to
Bob and Earl to what has been known in
in primate in non-human primates and
that is something called repetition
suppression that a familiar odor tends
familiar stimulus rather tends to
produce less of a response in neurons in
the visual system when it's repeated so
so we would argue that this looks like a
fly analog of this kind of phenomenon
okay now again because it's a fly we can
look a little bit into mechanism what's
causing this adaptation specific
adaptation to occur and of course you
immediately suspect it has something to
do with the dopamine on because dopamine
is the trigger of plasticity in this
system known from the classical
conditioning type experiment so here is
the dopamine neuron in question you can
see it's feeding into the same area from
which the M bond gets its its input and
so what what about that dopamine neuron
the first thing is it responds to odor
it's better because if it's going to
responsible for the plasticity that
shuts down the specific odor response it
better respond and remember that
dopamine tends to weaken synapses in
this system so this looks like the right
kind of thing the dopamine is responding
maybe the synapses are getting weaker
and to to show that
daisuke used one of the genetic tricks
you know you this is
yeast transcription factor that has been
split into so that it can be very
specifically expressed in these ppl one
alpha prime 3 dopamine neurons this is
then the the you know the expression
system that allows a potassium channel
to be expressed if you have one of these
alone you don't get expression of the
potassium channel and you get the usual
kind of you know reduction of response
upon repetition of the odor but if you
block the activity of this with this
potassium channel being expressed now
you lose that that's that thing so the
the model here is that you start off
with a system like this let's say with
strong synapses we suppose we have an
odor that activates these green Kenyan
cells it gives a strong response in the
N bond but after you've had dopamine
release in this system due to again the
the activation by order of the ppl one
neuron those synapses get weak and
output nonstops to respond but you
notice that that's odor specific because
these other synapses here have remained
strong so later if you have an odor
coming on you know these two Kenyan
cells you'll get a strong response to it
so that's the basis of this system okay
let me go back in and set this up so the
idea that gets weaker now what you might
say and actually this is what Mars 69
paper worried a lot about is okay this
sounds cool but you only have so many
synapses here so you know if I have
another odor that activates these two
there needs to synapse to get weaker
then I activate these two needs to get
weaker pretty soon I'll have nothing but
weak synapses in the whole neuron will
be shot and now when I come up with a
another novel odor the system is dead so
how do you avoid that well a smart idea
would be to say if you're exposed to a
lot of novel odors
you better start recovering the memory
so in other words if this is the first
novel odor but then I'm supposing this
fly is exposed a whole lot up more you
better recover these synapses and say I
can't remember everything I'm just going
to remember you know the most recent one
and that in fact that's exactly what
happened
so if you look at this phenomenon which
remember lasted a half an hour but you
exposed the fly to a lot of novel odors
in this period you get a recovery
furthermore you you can do this
artificially by activating the dopamine
neurons so our hypothesis for what
happened there was that the dopamine
neuron was activated in the absence of
that of the triggering odor of that of
the novel odor and so you can do that
with light so you can use
channelrhodopsin or crimson in this case
to activate the dopamine neuron so
normally here you in the absence of that
of the crimson you you get a prolonged
suppression of this response but if you
activate the dopamine neuron it starts
to recover so it looks like this system
is smartly built that if you have a lot
of novel odors it could starts to forget
the the earlier ones and and keep the
synapses alive for new novelty okay so
that's just just expressed here that in
other words that the same signal that
would take these synapses and weaken
them would take inactive synapses these
guys which were learned earlier so odor
a weakened these synapses but you
haven't seen odor a in a while then the
idea is dopamine in the absence of
activity on the kenyan cells would
strengthen them back so the learning
rule if you want here is dopamine +
kenyan cell activity at a synapse
weakens it dopamine alone without Kenyan
cell activity strengthens it that's then
that that rule has been seen in other
compartments okay so alright so to wind
up I guess I got too blind up here so
I'm going to move is there any
relationship between the two phenomenon
I showed you so I've shown you that this
these output neurons are actually two of
them alpha prime 3 output not suppress
their activity upon repetitive exposure
to an odor and we've seen that the
alerting response gets suppressed in in
response to repetitive
bozhe - an odor so is there any
relationship between these two so one
experiment is to activate this output
neuron up to genetically again with
crimson and again the two controls which
are zero here are having either one
component or the other component of the
expression system and so there is no
crimson expressed in those animals okay
so if you activate the output neuron
with light in fact you do induce the
cessation of grooming in in these
animals expressing the crimson but it
has no effect on grooming for the
animals that don't express crimson so
activating this cell does indeed stop
grooming it stops grooming actually at
about the same level as it does in the
in the wild-type animal these aren't the
wild-type animals but they're the same
as that furthermore if you add light to
an odor so in this case there's odor so
these control flies are behaving the
same as the light here but now these
flies really really hope so they're
getting a double dose of novelty if you
want you think that was novel try this
okay now the more impressive experiment
I think actually is the silencing
experiment so again this potassium
channel was now expressed in the output
neuron genetically so in the yellow it's
being expressed in the two colors of
blue those are those are the two sides
of the genetic cross and what you can
see is again about half the fly stop
normally but if you silence this output
neuron you don't get the stopping so
this is as if the fly does not recognize
a novel odor as novel so you haven't
taken out familiarity you take out
novelty there's no there's no alerting
novel response if you repeat of course
these guys go down the controls go down
but actually nothing happens to this
silenced one so we think that we've
removed the ability to detect the novel
order from these flies therefore they
don't alert to a novel odor okay I guess
that just that's just saying that that's
yeah that's
that's us that just says do this is this
is Richard congratulating himself okay
all right so I want to wind up with it
with one more thing I started to talk
with these two different forms of
computing one in which you've got lots
of recurrent connections between neurons
with many connections in this circuit
you tend to have a laborat
it's not clear maybe there's a little a
less elaborate and inhibition over here
but in this circuit you have this
incredible change from a set of neurons
setting up the signal with very few
synapses to a set of neurons receiving a
lot so the first thing we asked he at
this point again this is going back I
should have mentioned the stuff I did on
the two halves of the brain that was
Evan Schafer's work and now I'm going
back to a Shooks work so so the system
we've talked about has a random
connections here and then learned or
plastic connections here but we asked
you know what if you sorry I should have
an arrow here but what if you extend the
plasterer now sorry I can I can do it
now I just got confused on your grant
project so if you look at that system as
a function of the number of connections
III basically showed you at a certain
point it doesn't pay to add connections
so that this is just repeating what I
already showed you - no - I apologize
for having screwed it up okay now we
were saying what if you extended the
plasticity to this layer not have to be
careful here I don't mean any kind of
plasticity if you add a homeostatic kind
of a regulatory plasticity to this layer
it's a really good idea the system works
better but I'm talking about the kind of
learning based you know dopamine
activated or climbing fiber activated
learning extended not just here but here
and what we found kind of no matter what
learning rule we used it didn't make any
difference it kind of makes sense
because these cells get so few inputs
that there's nothing to tune right
there's no there's no system to it and
so state another way this really says
that role
that random is the best you can do here
if you adjust for a particular task
you're not going to do any better than
random so in this in this mode of
operation there's no point in having
supervised you know dopamine or climbing
fiber controlled learning one step back
okay now we asked another question which
is so-so in that system
don't bother what if you had lots of
synapses here this is not the way the
system is built but it's the way for
example machine learning build systems
tend to be built you have tons of
connections here now what happens if you
do plasticity there so now I have to go
to the right this is now lots of
connections and now learning which is
the red curve a way outperforms the the
non learning case so the idea here just
I wind up is that we have these two
domains of computation we have what I
call a cerebellar or cerebellar like I
have to be careful and say cerebellar
cortex and not overstated but you have a
domain where all the learning is put
onto the output that makes learning
relatively simple and it makes it
extremely fast so I would argue that
these systems are for rapid learning but
not you know for let's say poetry or
symphony composing out here you have a
system where you it really pays to have
learning spread throughout the system
and it's a more powerful system as a
result I mean it greatly outperforms
this system and I would argue that's the
cortical domain it takes longer to learn
things but you know you can learn to
play a piano concerto probably need a
cerebellum to do that too
bad example okay so so within that
machine I want to get back to this
marriage of machine learning and
neuroscience which I truly believe is
going to be a big thing in the coming
years I mean any idiot would say that
okay and that is that these systems that
learn on the output our systems like the
mushroom body the e ll the cerebellum
that I've been describing
structured this way they work extremely
well that you have to pay the price of
having a whole lot of granule cells to
pull this off but they're perfectly fine
within the machine learning a community
this is sometimes called extreme
learning now there's another system sort
of based on this kind of idea where you
you learn in two stages
I'm arguing that sort of the way cortex
was gone somehow
it figured out how to extend the sort of
learning of a task back to previous and
recurrence synapses and in the machine
learning community of course this is the
deep network revolution that you know
Jim and collaborators have have done so
nice a job of exploiting to help us
understand the visual system so in these
systems down here we know how it's done
it's done by a scheme called back
propagation which figures out not only
how to adjust these synapses but how to
adjust these I think one of the main
challenges and one of the main ways that
we can play these against each other is
to figure out how this guy figures out
how to do that those connections all
right I'll stop there and take any
questions
[Applause]